claude blanchemaison bonjour bonjour
ravi de vous retrouver ce matin sur rtl
france alors qu'elle est l'objet de
cette réunion à paris- centré sur
l'afrique est bien comme vous venez de
lire le fait générateur c'est la
constatation il ya un an et demi du d'un
besoin de financement de l'afrique
d'environ 300 milliards de dollars dans
les trois prochaines années qui invité
qui participent à cette réunion
un certain nombre de chefs d'état
africains pour le nord de l'afrique
le président de l'égypte et le tunisien
pour la partie afrique australe l'angola
et le mozambique pour l'afrique de
l'ouest la côte d'ivoire et le sénégal
plus un certain nombre d'autres pays
dans le président de la république du
congo puisque c'est lui qui exerce
actuellement la présidence de l'union
africaine des organisations
internationales
la directrice générale du fonds
monétaire international c'est très
important parce qu'on va discuter de la
dette africaine parce qu'on va discuter
également de l'octroi à l'afrique le
droit tirage spéciaux qui sont un moyen
de financement propre au fonds monétaire
international
et puis l'union européenne parce que
depuis le début depuis l'origine du
marché commun l'union européenne à un
vaste programme de coopération avec
l'afrique qui a beaucoup évolué avec
tous les pays africains qu'ils soient
francophones anglophones lusophones et
actuellement ce schéma prévoit 14
milliards d'euros de financement sur sur
quatre ans sur quatre ou cinq ans c'est
à dire sur la période pour la période
actuelle
donc il y aura il y a également
aujourd'hui le président charles michel
la présidente de la commission ursula
von der leyen et josette borel donc les
grands acteurs
de la coopération et puis un certain
nombre d'états africains qui sont
représentatifs de l'ensemble de la
communauté
les états africains alors je crois que
le premier point à l'ordre du jour sans
effet le financement de la dette la
dette qui n'est pas en valeur en valeur
relative des pnb si importante que cela
sauf que la plupart des pays africains
n'ont pas les moyens de la financer
et que par conséquent il y a lieu
probablement de faire en sorte que le
club de paris puisque c'est là que se
décident les ré seulement de la dette
que se décide
l'effacement de la dette c'est la
réunion des directeurs du trésor des
pays concernés et bien se prononce sur
ce sujet mais on en parlera évidemment
dans la conférence d'aujourd'hui avec
également l'attribution de droits de
tirage spéciaux du fmi puisque il va y
avoir une émission droits de tirage
spéciaux pour un montant très important
l'afrique compte tenu de sa part dans le
capital du fmi
on obtiendra automatiquement que 33
milliards et la question qui se pose sur
la base d'une proposition française et
européenne c'est la redistribution
droits de tirage spéciaux des pays
développés à l'afrique et un certain
nombre de pays sont favorables à cette
initiative
je veux lui dire aussi que évidemment du
côté européen participé à cette réunion
le président en exercice du conseil
européen c'est à dire le premier
ministre portugais président en exercice
de l'union européenne pour six mois
et puis l'espagne et l'italie pourquoi
parce que ce sont les pays du sud de
l'europe qui sont le plus exposées aux
flux migratoires et que pour éviter les
flux migratoires le moyen le plus
évident c'est évidemment le
développement alors que l'autre comment
s'articule la coopération internationale
en afrique avec les états unis et la
chine par exemple
alors obama avait
développer une coopération africaine
assez significative et en 2014 les états
unis ont tenu un sommet etats unis
afrique avec beaucoup de chefs d'état
africains
par ailleurs l'agencé de développement
américaine à des programmes bien entendu
sur un grand nombre de pays d'afrique le
président trump qui ne connaissait pas
l'afrique a plus ou moins interrompu
cette politique et qui reprend
maintenant avec le président joe biden
et on constate que en effet des gens qui
connaissent l'afrique font partie de son
entourage proche et qui l'a nommé au
poste de responsable des agences de
développement américaine ddd des gens de
premier plan qui connaissent en effet
l'afrique donc les etats-unis reviennent
sur l'afrique et vont avoir un rôle plus
important la chine la chine est un
acteur ancien puisque depuis très
longtemps
la chine construit des infrastructures
en afrique il ya 25 ans on montrait les
grands stades où les où les routes
construites par la chine populaire et
aujourd'hui on montre le train un
nouveau train entre nairobi et mombasa
qui remplace le vieux train du data one
big toe ria mais qui est le train à
l'infrastructure ferroviaire qui a coûté
le plus cher au kilomètre c'est un rire
évidemment un inconvénient notamment
pour les kenyans qui vont avoir à
rembourser les prêts qui ont été faits
par la chine
ça fait aussi partie du sujet l'un des
vice premiers ministres chinois va
participer à la conférence d'aujourd'hui
par vidéoconférence et c'est un bon
c'est pas bon si ça veut dire que la
chine souhaite entrer dans une
coopération positive avec l'afrique et
quel point sérieux le problème de la
dette africaine alors ceriani lavrov lui
s'exprime aujourd'hui lors d'une
conférence sur les relations avec
l'afrique justement à ce que la russie
aussi à des relations importantes avec
l'afrique aujourd'hui
bien sûr et c'est d'ailleurs une
relation traditionnelle d'abord il faut
signaler je crois qu un assez grand
nombre de responsables africains ont
fait des études à l'université du mans
bat l'université pour l'amitié des
peuples à moscou et que par conséquent
ils ont des liens personnels avec la
russie en deuxième lieu la lumière
poutine a multiplié les voyages en
afrique à partir de 2006 pour nouer des
liens de coopération économique
et puis ensuite la russie a passé un
certain nombre d'accords y compris les
accords de coopération militaire avec
une quinzaine de modèles de pays
africains pour former des cadres
militaires avec une coopération public
privé qui s'exerce dans plusieurs pays
africains
il y a eu en 2019 un sommet russie
afrique à sotchi avec la participation
d'environ 45 chefs d'état africains il
est prévu qu'il y en ait un autre
probablement l'année prochaine à addis
abeba puisque c'est le siège de
l'organisation du thé africaine et il y
a donc aujourd'hui cette rencontre en
partie en vidéo conférence à l'académie
diplomatique russe à moscou et à un
discours important de monsieur sergueï
lavrov de mise affaires étrangères russe
qu'il exposera la conception qu'a la
russie du développement de l'afrique et
du rôle que la russie petit jouet rock
il faut dire que tous les acteurs sont
les bienvenus parce que le problème est
d'une telle amplitude que la chine doit
tiendra sa part la russie doit y avoir
c'est pas bien sûr les états unis
bien sûr les pays développés que tout le
monde doit avoir sa part et qu'il faut
probablement que ans comme ça a été dit
tout à l'heure
cette coopération
prennent un cours nouveau ça a déjà
commencé d'ailleurs et qu'elle soit très
largement cogérer cogérée par les
africains belle il s'agit pas d'imposer
des solutions il faut en effet que les
projets les programmes soient cogérée
par les donateurs et par les pays
bénéficiaires dans leur intérêt et
surtout que l'on n'alourdisse pas la
dette de certains pays africains en
construisant des infrastructures qui ne
s'imposent pas complètement ou alors il
faut et bien faire des dons si ce qui se
passe d'ailleurs pour les pays africains
les plus pauvres dont tout le monde sait
dans la communauté internationale qui ne
peuvent pas rembourser des emprunts
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison pour
cet éclairage un édito diplo à retrouver
sur les réseaux sociaux et puis on se
retrouve bien évidemment mardi prochain
claude blanchou